[Music]
so first rules help me okay well it just
like you cooking a sticky that looked so
easy for you and not as much for me but
there's general rule of thumb for for
punting is all on the drop
amazingamazing so it's gonna literally
hit you're aiming to get in there
correct yeah just like shape we want it
you want to hit that solid part of your
foot just like you would in soccer and
everything point the nose down a little
bit yeah and so it's just I can see that
you played a lot of soccer yes and the
sense that you may might have done some
goalie at some choice you always see the
goalies just give that little yeah
little throw up
whereas here giving that little throw up
and then the wind that we have causes
the wind to take it which it did correct
and so that's where we we have to focus
on holding on to the ball and almost
making contact out of our hands so it's
directional so when you'll point to
those numbers it's going nowhere but
that correct you want it to go right
there somewhere in there and then you
got to play the wind factor and so then
then you have punts like this where
they're turnovers and with the wind the
way it is and at our back if we were
punting this way the wind so you hit
down the side
well this you're hitting at the top
still want to hold like this and I think
of hitting somewhere right here so I pay
attention to the for me I'm pay
attention to the sea and American
Football Conference don't you thought
was a lefty I'd probably be playing the
e of the National Football conscience
and so you sit there and drop it ball
points to maybe eleven thirty right on a
clock if the clock was laying down side
on
sidon just exactly like that
so with this wind it's gonna be
difficult because the wind is pushing
this ball and it's not allowing it to
turn over this is my shape ball yes it
is
so you know you you know a lot about
these ones as well right yeah I grew up
playing that I'm not the first one to
kick a soccer ball here is it no no no
come over hit one in the goal there
let's do that shall we
sorry cameraman you have to just move
back two meters so but oh you go to the
bar okay
yes ah you know the advantage I have is
I actually have a kick and shoes yes you
have
clown boots on right now sighs oh man
isn't your with lovely I'm gonna go in
the kitchen and thank you so much well
you can wear that next time you cook now
got it one for the road
yeah figure it out so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]